back in 2008 the most common word
searched on Google as well as the most
common word used in book titles was the
word happy happy everybody won't know
how to be happy after the market tanked
38% nowadays everybody wants to use the
word entrepreneur but there's another
one that's being tossed around by people
and it's called disruptor
he's a disruptor I'm a disruptor she's a
disruptor we're disruptors everybody's a
disruptor let's hold ants and become
disruptors everybody wants to be
disruptive well listen there are 4 C
letter words you need to go through to
be considered a disruptor in your
marketplace I'm gonna tell you about
what this really means many many years
ago when I got into the financial
industry I didn't really know if I could
do it or not I had no background the
financial industry nothing so I get in
and in all of us on I get my series 766
3126 life and up I start doing a
business it's kind of cool
October of oh 9 we decided to start our
an insurance company from the moment I
started an insurance company five
seconds later four hundred billion
dollar company sued us with a 400-page
lawsuit I mean 400 page lawsuit out to
get attorneys to represent seven
different of us like we have to go
through right and so we start the
company we're about to go out of
business what we're fighting we're
selling we're working a hundred hundred
twenty hours a week we're barely
sleeping at night we made it long story
show but this is what took place and
insurance magazine calls me says we like
to get together with you because we know
you like to get your credibility because
you just went through lawsuit the
marketplace doesn't really see you as a
company that's coming up we can really
help you by getting your credibility up
I said let's get together they come down
to Woodland Hills we sit down at
Woodland Hills Maggiano's and they
present the fact that I can be on the
cover of their number one insurance life
insurance mags in the marketplace over a
hundred fifty thousand subscribers you
can be on the cover of it I said Wow
coverage says no advertorial advertorial
is this this rips off this is not the
cover that's not the cover this is the
cover this is an advertorial $425,000 I
said you want me to pay you 125 they
said yes I said look I'll get the bill
tonight I'm not gonna pay you hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars but very
soon you will contact us and you'll ask
us to do a cover story on your magazine
oh that won't happen I said why not that
just won't happen I said look at me my
eyes I'm gonna tell you four words here
okay
I said ma'am very nice lady I said you
have no idea how much conviction I have
in the life insurance industry I love
this business I know people think I'm
crazy I love their life insurance in
this dress number one you can't teach
conviction you had to have it or you
don't have it number two when you get
into an industry you decide to compete
the C letter would compete when you
compete I wanted to find out if I had
the goodies to compete in the
marketplace I figured I could compete
with a lot of people in the marketplace
that was number two number three the
industry gave me so much my lifestyle my
freedom all this other stuff I said I
wanted to contribute to the industry I
want to find a way to make the industry
better because without this industry
this regular guy whose father worked out
of 99 cents or who at a 1.8 GPA who went
to the military I've never had a
four-year two-year degree he would have
been a regular guy right and a 40 letter
word it's challenging conventional
thinking which by the way if you're
involved in the industry and you don't
challenge everybody's way of thinking
where people are dying for you to go out
of business you're not really disrupted
listen we had so many people wanted us
to go out of business they started
propagandas rumors all of this stuff
because they were furious with us by the
way a lot of lonely nights a lot of
nights of clothes are being out of
business a lot of crazy days but then
one day I get a phone call a man named
Paul calls me he's the CEO and the
founder says I'm the co-founder of this
magazine I said Paul what's the purpose
of the call it says I'd like to talk
about telling your story because I'm
seeing what you're doing the market
place your name is coming up by people
who like you and your name is coming up
by people who don't like you and some
even hate you but I figure it's a good
time for us to share your story with
people what do you think I said great
let's talk about it I said is this an
advert or EB cuz I have no interest in
spending a single penny says no no no we
want to do a cover story
and we want to tell your story so they
came they did two articles one was
called can he make insurance cool again
as you see it on the screen and the
other one was a cover story of what they
recently did that was called Patric bit
David is turning non agents into super
sellers and so after this they came to
the home office many of you ask me all
the time Pat what do you do for a living
I run a financial firm that's what I do
for a living I make videos you know what
time it is right now it is right in our
928 this is when we make videos believe
it or not later not because we don't
have time to make
videos throughout the day but this
interview that was done by Matt Walton
will tell you exactly what I do on a
daily basis enjoy the interview this is
Matt Walton with leaders of Industry
today we're down in Dallas Texas to meet
the hugely successful author and
entrepreneur Patrick BETT David the
founder of the PHP agency' which stands
for people helping people and value
tainment this is his corporate
headquarters it's going immediately the
life insurance industry is in retreat
today the big agencies have all but
given up on new recruits as more people
are leaving the business than entering
it but Patrick that David is on the
advance personally bringing nearly 4,000
new agents into the field and turning
many into millionaires we started with
Patrick and I never looked back and how
much business did you do last year like
millions of dollars hey we're talking
about the things that were able to have
in terms of removing financial arguments
out of our conversation and our
relationship is much more enhanced as a
young boy Patrick that David immigrated
to the United States from war-torn Iran
served in the US Army's 101st airborne
unit and soon set off on a one-man
mission to save the insurance industry
from self-destruction a true industry
disrupter pH P's model how they serve
the customer they're really approaching
the industry in a unique fun and
innovative way I thought this was a
noble company selling a noble product
life insurance and I said man it would
be an honor to help you donation line
at the same Absalon he's published four
books and with close to a hundred
million views on social media he's built
the preeminent YouTube channel on
entrepreneurship value tainment and he's
done all of this before even turning 40
making Patrick bet David an undisputed
leader of Industry it's quite a
reception yeah yes he gets a lot of
attention I was in Las Vegas we're
having lunch at Joe's and Caesars and I
see this massive Optimus Prime and I
said I gotta have you know I may be
agent when I'm still a kid inside I like
my toys I go in the girl says it's
handmade by a whole party she says Honda
right here and it's nine feet tall 1,400
pounds I took eight people to put this
thing up so it's a pretty grand entrance
we should run I'm sure the office
[Music]
he's built a place where you come you
eat play like football either playing
along you look like you're competitive
[Music]
you go to the gym didn't work out today
I want to get lifted in a suit this is a
massive office it's all Hollywood I'm
right on movies tombstone Rocky Batman
and we see a lot of superheroes I also
watch a movie have popcorn relax
this painting is a special painting I
will be so impressed if you get all
night it's the most famous one of all
yeah I love that guy you got to pop down
got a b got JFK and einstein you got one
mr. King Shah of Iran okay the Shah of
Iran
most people think this is buff but it's
Milton Friedman okay this is sent out
his story just fascinates me I love this
guy's story so much where I name my
daughter
Senna oh wow his last name is son of my
daughter's first myth sent up so he's
close to the left because that's my
heart this is my daughter
Patrick Beth David tell me about growing
up in Iran I was born October of 78
which is a peak of the revolution
between the Shah and the whole thing
that was going on so when my father was
taking my mother to the hospital when
her water broke was curfew so I held up
my dad and had to escort my mom to the
hospital and then I was born and then
three months later the shah's out right
and then it's Iran with the turmoil a
war between Iran and Iraq I remember one
day we got bombed 167 times in a single
day and in one day Khomeini dies well
how many days June 3rd 89 six weeks
later we escaped how and we escaped we
won and said we're going to Germany on
vacation but we didn't go on vacation we
went a state at a refugee camp in
Germany how was the refugee camp was
that like it's pretty well you know it
you'd wake up in the morning you go to
the corner end of it they would put the
apple juice you pick up the apple juice
there were people there from Yugoslavia
Albania Poland
it's just Afghanistan Iraq everybody was
leaving to come to America so you learn
about a lot of different cultures is the
first time I
stabbed was at the refugee camp it was
just craziness then we got our green
card from the states then we flew in
November 28 1990 came to the States did
your father put the idea of coming to
America in your head was did he have
eyes on I mean at what point did you
think America is where I wanted so I
asked my dad this question a couple
years ago my dad gave the credit to my
mom my parents got a divorce but my dad
said your mother said we gotta leave
because in Iran if you turn I think 12
years old you have to serve and so
didn't want me to stay in Malawi no at
12 you can't leave so you have to stay
to serve and so my parents said we gotta
leave we don't want you to serve it's so
funny I left there and I come to America
and I serve in the US it's which my
mother wasn't too happy about but it
kind of worked out you had aspired to be
the Iranian Arnold Schwarzenegger yes
did you think that training in the army
was going to help you meet that goal or
so if you came unto my barracks and the
army I had pictures of Arnold or had
pictures of John Travolta that was that
was my you know barracks and John
Travolta because of sad Saturday night
she stayed alive you know that hope my
barracks we will play that every day and
so I got out and I said you know what I
can work hard I know how to train I'm
gonna go be a bodybuilder
his story was I'm gonna be the Middle
Eastern Arnold and when did that story
change direction how's that Venice Beach
no shirt on cockiness you know one of
these guys walking around and his girl
approaches me and we kind of made eye
contact she approaches me she comes up
and we start talking we start dating she
said I work out Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter I said I know nothing about
Morgan Stanley what's Morgan Stanley she
said it's a financial firm all this
other stuff said how can I work over
there she said you need a four-year
degree she wants UCLA I said I'm not
doing that so I took my resume which was
very impressive Bob's Big Boy Burger
King haagen-dazs and you were trying be
the top sales guy at those places like
that is my resume no for you know to
your nothing on the cover letter I took
my best joke that I had and I put the
joke with the resume on the bottom of
the joke I said if you're laughing this
is exactly how my customers are gonna
feel when they do business with me if
you want someone like me part of your
team give me a call
guy so I sent a hundred back then with
facts you wouldn't you know there was no
monster I faxed a hundred thirty called
me out of the thirty fifteen were just
impressed by the joke well say good joke
the joke was father dies before he dies
he tells us three sons listen every one
of you I want you to drop a thousand
dollars in my coffin because I want the
family to know how much you love your
dad and it's a way of paying back to
your daddy all this son said no problem
daddy so the funeral comes first son
shows up
it throws ten hundred dollar bills
everybody starts crying oh my gosh you
know it's such a special thing second
son comes he throws twenty fifty dollar
bills oh my gosh what a beautiful son
third son comes he writes a three
thousand dollar cheque takes the toss
away is that I paid my debt but he got
the cash yes it's on theme and I'm Xing
you not get three offers I got three
offers one more again and I took the
Morgan and Glendale that's how I got
started there was a very significant
night in your life where you met
conservative columnist pundit genius
George Will yes so it's funny
politically I've always been confused my
mother said they believed in communism
and my dad said they believed in
imperialism because it is Shah so it's
polar opposites my mother thinks rich
people are greedy my dad used to believe
poor people are lazy
I'm absolutely confused I said don't
even talk about politics a man named
Bill Vogel
took me one night and he introduced me
to George Will and so I'm at Miramar
Hotel I'm having dinner with them and I
asked George will I said George you know
really trying to figure myself out what
do you recommend I do because I'm really
good trying to get clear about what I
wanted in my life he says look most
people your age could care less about
studying the history of what works and
what doesn't work as far as economical
systems why don't you go study
capitalism for the next 18 months I
bought every book on capitalism
socialism communism Communist Manifesto
Milton Friedman Karl Marx rules for
radicals you know Adam Smith in the
wealth of nations
Atlas Shrugged I said I want to find out
the math behind us why is there a group
that believes in this why is there a
group that believes in that and so all
of a sudden I started calling of
families of presidents I called the
Clinton family
family Carter family Reagan family I put
an event together
July 17th of oh nine called saving
America doing the impossible I was
dressed as George Washington
my wife was dressed as Lady Liberty had
another guy named Nick dressed as
Lincoln I had Michael Reagan speak I had
another guy speak on capitalism add
another guys speak on star-spangled
banner' I said that's what we're doing
and at three months later PHP got
started pH P stands for people helping
people
yes how did all your accumulated
knowledge of capitalism and how it
functions lead you to not only start
that company but name it people helping
people so you will never find a
billionaire who became a billionaire by
himself he just won't but he said that's
how the whole thing came about why we
should name the company PHP what strikes
me about the name is it's so
untraditional for a financial services
company
the alternative is what Patrick David
financial services right if I name my
name and some guys came and said why
don't you name the company your name you
got Morgan Stanley it's someone's name
Merrill Lynch Smith Barney Dean Witter
it's someone's name once you name the
company or name as I'm not gonna name
the company my name
PHP not only are your social media
numbers staggering you're the number of
agents you have it blows my mind
you know I'm compared to New York Life
you got like half their agents in your
in your one guy how did that happen
what's your secret I wanted to build a
company that I wanted to be a part of
very simple I wanted to build a business
that I would want from an outsider I
would love to be part of this company so
what is that I want to own a piece of
the company equity because in case some
happens I'm also protected perfect that
was one too I wanted to create an
incentive program that doesn't benefit
just the people that have been on for 20
years it benefits the small business
owner and so I wanted to create an
environment where the newest agent
coming in had the same amount of
opportunity as a guy that had been on
for nine years you'll hear a lot of
times financial firms say to following
lies our executive team has over 400
years of experience am I supposed to be
impressed right when you say that to me
no it's the first thing I think about
that means are golfing because they're
done creating new experiences so first
thing I think about and by the
it's not a good slogan anymore it used
to be not today because the new
generation is no longer the baby boomers
that's the biggest
you got Gen Xers you got Millennials
they want to connect with somebody so
for us our average agent today is a 34
year old Hispanic female today in PHP
which is the United States of America
versus just one audience that doesn't
necessarily connect with everybody how
do you connect with Millennials because
you're kind of in between Gen X and
millennial line 39 yes so you're right
in the in the in the mitts you got to
settle to me as a millennial talk to my
heart
stop talking to my brain move me get me
emotional make me feel like it can be
part of something bigger if we can
communicate this language to Millennials
and Gen X's holy moly the amount of
potential that we can tap into it's
priceless well I think you were
successful in doing that with your video
the life of an entrepreneur in 90
seconds the number of views it got in
just 48 hours is mind-blowing bridging
the career of financial adviser
insurance agent into the title of
entrepreneur when does that happen
and what does that mean I was with Videl
eyes yes two days ago at his house not a
name drop you hear very well but I see
but I got together with them and I'm
sinner saying you know look at this guy
here he's an artist he was a rap or
hip-hop whatever but that's an artist
entrepreneur there's not a big
difference because it's creativity right
I mean you look at yourself you're in
the entertainment business we have so
many commonalities with entrepreneurs
more than anything else it was a message
to tell entrepreneurs you're not alone
this thing is tough but believe me the
glory feels so good
hang in there it's all gonna be all
right that's what's so effective about
it now
I want to finish with what that video
then became our businesses and people
defined by their social media followers
and their numbers and their likes now or
is it just fancy packaging is it just
sort of a badge so what value take we
became videos and I chose one word it
was entrepreneur we make life of an
entrepreneur and life of an entrepreneur
takes off on YouTube I put it on you too
and we called it the best motivational
video of 2015 24 hours against 2500
views nothing and I said I'm gonna
change the title on Facebook and I
change the title to a life of an
entrepreneur 90 seconds and so let's
just test this out two hours later it's
got 265 thousand views so what is going
on with this
the next morning every one of our
websites has shut down it's 2 million
with 5 million views 30 days later 10
million views today's at 31 million
views and it goes bonkers that video
gave traffic to the DNA of an
entrepreneur so they went there from
there they went to DNA one entrepreneur
and then they said this guy kind of
knows what he saw my wood business
antibody team and became what it is
today I think today we have two brands
one brand is actual business the other
brand is your brand
very simple you today have a brand every
CEO every entrepreneur every salesperson
has a brand today Richard Branson you
didn't know who he was and then also my
gosh this guy's going on a you know
balloon and he's doing it yeah you like
I like this guy so cool he jumps out of
this so he built his own brand and a
virgin took off there's a darker side to
it you're gonna be exploited you can't
have a private life within ten minutes I
can find out if you're Republican or
Democrat it's very easy I can find out
if you're got kids if you're a sports
guy who do you like I can get 50
questions answered in five minutes you
can do that 20 years ago so we're all
naked today so today my suggestion to
everybody is here's a company people
want to know who's behind the company
tell us your story what do you like what
are you about
tell us about your mom your dad your
upbringing who were you what you
struggle with what's your biggest
challenge in life what do you fear what
do you like what do you love I want to
get to know you and the more I get to
know you the more I follow up with the
brand here Paget vet David you're a
leader of industry
I appreciate that brother thanks for
having thanks for having me
and we got a crazy slide here I'm gonna
go down that side
oh man yeah it's no joke that is true
leadership in the insurance industry if
you're an agent or any kind of
entrepreneur make sure you check out
Patrick BETT David's YouTube channel
value tainment until then I'm Matt
Walton with leaders of Industry